When it comes to landing Hollywood's most
coveted roles, even established actors have
to show a little hustle.
With the knowledge that Ben Affleck will no
longer be reprising his role as the Caped
Crusader for director Matt Reeves' The Batman,
an actor from DC's Man of Steel has tossed
his name into the running for the gig.
While the next standalone Batman movie was
originally set to be written by, directed
by, and star Ben Affleck, the two-time Batman
actor has instead stepped back, leaving the
role wide open.
Since then, fans have been buzzing about which
stars might step up and don the cape and cowl
in Affleck's stead.
The most recent name to pop up in association
with The Batman has been Robert Pattinson,
the British actor who broke into the mainstream
as the glittery vampire Edward Cullen in the
Twilight film franchise.
Though Pattinson has since gone on to prove
himself as a capable dramatic actor with movies
like Good Time and Maps to the Stars, the
internet still reacted somewhat poorly to
rumors of his involvement in The Batman.
The backlash gave other actors plenty of opportunities
to throw their own hats into the ring.
One voice in the anti-Pattinson-as-Batman
camp offered their own alternative thoughts
about who should play the lead in Reeves'
upcoming feature, instead pointing to Christopher
Meloni, who appeared as Colonel Nathan Hardy
in 2013's Man of Steel.
"This man is not our enemy."
"Thank you, Colonel."
Writing on Twitter in early February, user
Emily Diaz made an emphatic case for the longtime
character actor, writing, "NO, NO, and a million
times NO, dude!
Robert Pattinson would make a terrible Batman.
I think Chris Meloni would make an excellent
Batman-slash-Bruce Wayne."
Meloni, who is most recognizable from his
lead role as NYPD Detective Elliot Stabler
on Law & Order: Special Victims Unit, quickly
caught wind of the fan's desire to see him
grab the superhero torch from Affleck.
The actor took to his own Twitter page to
retweet the post, revealing that he would
indeed love to play the Batman.
As Meloni wrote in his post, "Yo DC Comics,
this is what the kids call, 'going VIRAL!'
Pull the trigger.
I'm ready.
I'm…
BATMAN."
Meloni as the Caped Crusader is a fun thing
to think about, and the actor is no stranger
to the world of comic books.
On top of his role in Man of Steel, the actor
has also appeared in the comic book adaptation
Sin City: A Dame to Kill For, based on the
comic series by Frank Miller, as well as the
SYFY TV series Happy, based on a mini-series
by Grant Morrison.
Meloni's enthusiasm is also a refreshing change
of pace from the last few years of Bat-Fleck,
which saw the Argo director seeming to become
less and less enthusiastic about the role.
Now that Affleck is moving out of Gotham City,
plenty of new actors' names have emerged for
consideration, including English actor Jack
O'Connell, Stranger Things star Dacre Montgomery,
and singer-songwriter Nick Jonas.
When Reeves first signed on to direct The
Batman, it was briefly rumored that the Dawn
of the Planet of the Apes director wanted
Jake Gyllenhaal in the lead role, a possibility
that Gyllenhaal himself later shot down.
Gyllenhaal instead signed on with Marvel Studios
to play the villain in Spider-Man: Far From
Home.
Another actor who's been rumored to be angling
for the role is Mad Men star Jon Hamm, who
was once said to be "gunning hard" for the
gig.
However, it seems unlikely that either he
or Meloni will ultimately get the part.
Unfortunately, despite Meloni's enthusiasm,
it doesn't seem likely that Reeves and company
will end up selecting him for the role.
One limiting factor is Meloni's age, with
his 57 years falling far outside the late-20s-to-early-30s
range that Warner Bros. seems to be looking
for.
It's been reported that Reeves' take on The
Batman will focus on a younger version of
the caped crusader, which stands in contrast
to Affleck's version of an older, grizzled,
more world-weary character.
Meloni may be a versatile actor, but a young
man he is not.
Despite all that, history tells us that nothing
is set in stone when it comes to The Batman,
so if the producers of the movie decide on
a radically different approach, Meloni is
waiting in the wings to take the job.
And if he doesn't get the lead role, who knows,
he might still end up in the movie.
Donald Glover's campaign to play Spider-Man
didn't get him cast as the webslinger, but
he did still end up in Spider-Man: Homecoming.
Maybe Meloni could get cast as a villain,
and put his intensity to good use against
whoever ends up actually donning the cowl.
We'll find out what happens when The Batman
hits theaters on June 25th, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.